et cette guerre qui a détourné les
regards vous le savez he d'une autre
région c'est c'est l'Ukraine on a appris
en fin de matinée ces coupures d'ampleur
près de 2 millions de personnes sont
actuellement privées d'électricité en
Russie mais aussi en Ukraine occupé la
Crimée en cause ce n'est pas pour une
fois la guerre en cours dans la région
mais ces violentes intempéré qualifié de
méga tempêtes vous en apercevez ici les
images de nouvelles difficultés qui
viennent s'ajouter au conflit en
l'Ukraine continue à infliger de lourdes
pertes à la Russie c'est ce qui estimé
en fin de matinée le chef de l'OTAN on
va aller prendre le pou tout de suite du
côté de Kiev avec notre correspondant
Guliver Krag bonjour Guliver quelles
sont précisément les les nouvelles du
terrain
aujourd'hui alors si les ukrainiens et
leurs alliés à l'international mettent
l'accent sur les perte infligé à la
Russie sur avdfka et aux alentours de
cette ville qui est toujours contrôlé
par l'Ukraine mais juste au nord de
Donetsk contrôlé par la Russie depuis
2014 la Russie attaque et subit des
pertes records selon les renseignements
britanniques notamment en terme de
nombre d'hommes tués par mèes Carr gagné
mais tout de même il gagne petit à petit
des mètres carrés et de la veu de un
commandant ukrainien qui s'est exprimé à
la télé ukrainienne ce matin euh il
contrôlerait les russe en ce moment une
partie de la zone industrielle au
sud-est de la ville d'avdivka donc entre
avdivka et donet cette zone qui depuis
2014 est vraiment une forteresse
ukrainienne la ligne de défense la plus
solide face au Russe qui depuis 2014 ont
fait des tentatives d'incursion dans
avdifka donc je pense que il y a risque
pour avdifka visiblement les Russes sont
prêt à subir des pertes extraordinaires
dans leur tentative de prendre cette
ville qui est stratégiquement important
pour eux sinon les Ukrainiens sont
encore en train d'attaquer au sud au sud
et à l'est de hererson de l'autre côté
du fleuve Nipro où ils auraient établi
une base mais visiblement il peineent à
vraiment avancer je vais parler il y a
quelques semaines avec des soldats
Ukrainiens qui disaient qu'il
redoutaient justement l'hiver et
l'arrivée de la neige parce que avec
l'activité des drones russes sur la
ligne de front il devient difficile de
reg gagner les positions en voit ou en
véhicule parce que les véhicules sont
plus faciles à repérer et à frapper pour
les drones il faut y aller à pied c'est
une chose assez difficile déjà quand il
fait beau quand il a la naise c'est
d'autant plus difficile h voilà pour ces
difficultés du terrain doublé de ces
craintes qui sont de plus en plus
exprimées par les Ukrainiens inqui de
voir la communauté internationale
finalement se se désintéresser de leur
guerre ce n'est pas uniquement le
désintérêt détournement de l'attention
c'est aussi la comparaison qui est
inévitablement faite entre le sort des
Ukrainiens et le sort des palestinien
même si les conflits sont vraiment
incomparables pour tout un tas de
raisons euh Joseph Borel le chef de la
diplomatie européenne disait qu'il
rencontre des difficultés euh quand il
dialogue avec d'autres pays membres des
Nations Unies pour essayer de rallier à
la position européenne des pays du Sud
notamment euh qui euh perçoivent une
certaine hypocrisie euh il voudrait voir
plus de condamnation d'Israël et plus de
soutien aux Palestiniens au même titre
que la communauté internationale
soutient l'Ukraine et donc sont plus
rétiscant à continuer à pororter leur
soutien à l'Ukraine mais bon la position
de l'Union européenne comme des
États-Unis reste que le soutien à
l'Ukraine continuera tant qu'il le
faudra verra yurova vice-président de la
Commission européenne est akev
aujourd'hui justement pour répéter cette
position là une preuve sera peut-être le
14 décembre c'est la prochaine date
intéressante pour l'Ukraine en terme de
négociation et diplomatie internationale
c'est là que l'Union européenne doit
donner sa décision si elle va ouvrir ou
non les pourparl pour l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne l'année
prochaine merci beaucoup goiverkrag
notre correspondant à Kiev les yeux